they grew up struggling with my weight
like many of the people that are you
know speaking today I started a company
based on my personal frustrations as the
biggest kid in the class feeling like
time and time again the products I
purchased the magazines I opened up the
programs I tried the TV shows I turned
on or not on my side or made me feel
worse about myself instead of better and
itself so at odds with the way the world
especially Millennials is hurting to
talk about health and wellness so at
odds of the way I wanted to here health
and wellness being talked about which
was not about health and fitness being
the point but about it just being a part
of living a better happier longer life
so this notion that this is a major
profound shift where 73 percent of
Millennials would rather be healthy even
wealthy so profoundly different from the
generations the past like the the notion
was like why aren't there brands and
businesses that speak to this so in the
last six years what we've done is try to
build that brand and we've done that
primarily through content so today we
write content we're a health and
wellness media website greatest com
check it out we have built a leading far
clearer and far away market leader in
terms a healthy mind of Millennials to
reach 10 to 50 million people every
single month using science fact expert
approved content that's fun and friendly
just like your friends a little further
along along the way we've raised eight
million dollars led by floodgate dream
investor we have were profitable now
which is pretty exciting you know not
making but loads of money yes that we're
on our way and what we're really doing
which is you know we're especially
excited about its taking this notion of
like a friend who's a little further
along which i think is a voice that we
were a 'king for that's been missing in
the space taking that voice and actually
productizing it so imagine if we could
pair you with a friend who's a little
further along you know just six months
ahead of you who can show you sort of
the path guide you towards where you
want to go maybe even pair you with a
group of people just like you who want
to accomplish the same goals on the same
timeline so now we're playing with a lot
of different stuff but if you want to
ask me about what it's like to run a
business for six years
how to start something that some people
every now and then will walk up to me
and be like you run that blog right and
being like no it's not a blog it's a
media company if you want to talk about
really anything the NBA draft my job is
to answer anything that you guys have
pressing and I was going to perform my
Nicki Minaj song but I'll do that later
any questions yes sir
I'm sure there's like mics or some
things don't actually told me how this
worked but I will listen to you Rodale
totally yeah so in case you didn't hear
at the way I understood the question at
least was like advertising is a pretty
mediocre business and elicitor Facebook
and how our media publisher is going to
monetize and you mentioned Rodale Rodale
actually just last I think this week
actually said that they are considering
a sale Rodale for those of you that
might not know men's health women's
health runners world this was the
largest private health and wellness
publisher actually one of the largest
private publishers period so the way we
think about this is that advertising is
actually a pretty great market obviously
some of the largest companies in the
world actually are built on advertising
but as a publisher especially as a niche
publisher that doesn't want to sell your
soul and doesn't want to yeah like sell
sell out and just write about Kim
Kardashian all day you do have to kind
of pursue other options but it's because
you don't write about Kim Kardashian of
all day that you can sort of double down
on the trust that you built I have
strong feelings about the market of
health and wellness as well I think if
you're building a publisher in news and
politics or media entertainment I think
it's really really really hard to figure
out how to charge your customers but my
guess is every single person in this
audience spend every month some amount
of money on health and wellness and if I
could tell you you could spend it on
from the will actually help you get
healthier you'd probably move you're
spending eighty percent of Millennials
today say they're spending on health and
wellness
they say on average they're spending 20%
of their annual income so gut check that
for a second does that seem right if
that's right that's four hundred and
twenty billion dollars being spent in
the United States right now on health
and wellness what are they spending it
on Andy cross paths which you'll hear
from payout later so yeah I think I
think it's really tight the market that
you're in and I think that there is a
massive opportunity to build this is my
opinion and my pitch ultimately when we
continue to grow is like my opinion is
there's enormous open opportunity in
health and wellness in terms of a
subscription you pay for every month
that actually drives you value peloton
is a perfect example but what's
something that like normal people can
afford and so I don't know if any of you
guys are working on any ideas we're
excited to hear about that I think my
name is Chuck Adi and I was curious as
an upstart media brand with a very
targeted demographic in 2017 what are
your thoughts about cannabis and its
contribution to health and wellness
amongst our generation were more
comfortable with it at the same time
that you guys are building a brand and
have you know a myriad of advertisers
and stakeholders that you have that
aside everyone is into wheat right now
right man like I have like so many
pitches on like weed infuses green juice
like I don't even understand
that's just weed juice yeah so I think
it's an enormous market I mean it's
definitely an enormous like economic
like opportunity especially as it
continues to expand and grow and be
legalized which you know is the only
something is it like it's starting to go
state by state I think in the media
space I would argue that we've has
actually been like covered a lot you
know high times has existed for longer
than like anyone can imagine
it's noop dog just bought it I could be
going crazy something like that actually
think that we'd probably is one of the
most oversaturated niche topics that
gets covered a lot in media but I think
if you're building a product and we
that's a a major opportunity
thank you other questions yes sir yeah
so we work with big steel brands almost
entirely and those were very proactively
going out to or they're coming in to us
but you know the only real way to
monetize online today is through sort of
these direct branded content
sponsorships which are you know
sometimes people will call them
advertising sometimes they won't
it's obviously advertising our pitch to
them is look we can activate and engage
Millennials to care about their health
better than anyone on the planet and we
speak their language better than your
brand will ever speak and so if you're
trying to introduce something new you're
trying to launch something new you're
trying to change something that people
didn't know before but like our finding
out that you know change the formula or
trying to introduce something new you
know that we can do that and help kind
of move the needle for you build
business build that brand awareness in a
different way but yeah the big brand
partnerships you know I've been doing
this for six years and greatest was not
always 10 to 15 million unique visitors
a month and when we were much smaller it
was much harder to get people to take
notice and in fact unfortunately I would
say that the goalpost or when you can
really start truly selling to these big
brands continues to move I remember when
we hit 5 million unique visitors I was
like this is it this is the moment and
then everyone was like now you need said
I was like and and then we got 10 at
everyone's like yeah but you don't have
30 so you know it's a it takes time to
get there yes hi this is Stephanie I'm
just curious to know if there's anything
coming up for you that you're excited
about in in my personal life of course
you mean your business yeah the thing
I'm most excited about is actually the
space in general I think health and
wellness I've alluded to it but I think
like this is the year like there are
businesses that are being built every
January for us is our Super Bowl you
know I don't know if you guys think of
January and are like this is the day
that I'm going this is
months and I'm going to get everything
on track well if it's not everyone else
is thinking that and so January becomes
the Superbowl and every January for the
last five years has just gotten bigger
and bigger in terms of how seriously
people are starting to take their health
and how much smarter they're getting
about building it into their lives so
I'm actually just really excited about
the continued increasing importance of
health and wellness and yeah I mean it
was not a thing if I was here four years
ago you know I'm pretty sure half the
speakers on this stage are like health
and wellness related or lifestyle
related in some way and that was not
true four years ago so I'm excited about
where it's all moving and where it's all
heading yes sir hey Derek
my name is dog well that's really
terrific my name is on it I'm really
curious to pick your brain on habit
formation could you talk about like you
know this notion that you just said
January's your Super Bowl that means
that there are a lot of new year's
resolution people coming coming to your
site to let her help right but how do
you sustain that motivation in that
energy so I have some strong opinions on
this greatest was really built the whole
actually name itself is not because I
don't know like I don't know how to
spell it's actually the idea is that
it's somebody who's trying to get better
like an artist works an art a greatest
just works on being greater they don't
have to be the greatest so this notion
of like it's all about actually in you
know kind of working at it and trying
and learning is what I think is the only
thing that really sticks is finding
what's good for you that you actually
enjoy and then you keep doing it over
time it's what I found time and time
again almost anyone who's doing like a
crash diet you know to accomplish a
certain goal if you're not going to end
up sticking to some of that stuff like
you're in trouble in my in my mind and
actually science says not only is yo-yo
dieting bad for you but look the country
has never been more abuse the world has
never been more obese and a big part of
that is because of but yet the but yet
we on average diet three to four times a
year in America which is crazy number so
so I think actually that the job is not
to change the behavior though I think
people do we just go through ups and
downs in terms of our motivation and I
like in the in the health world people
take January because they're always like
you know oh all these you know New
Year's resolution people are going to
like go into the gym and then they're
going to you know give it up for their
don't really mean it they'll give up
after 12 days but I actually think like
what an amazing opportunity of this
moment we're like I want to start fresh
I want to start new there are different
times that's to be asked throughout the
year and so the way I think of it is
don't change the behavior but actually
like embrace that and just make it
easier and more effective if people want
to commit to something I'm really
excited about I don't know if some of
you have heard of this dye called whole
30 I'm excited about this notion that
diets as we think of them are shifting
and that the new diet is actually a
short thing that you do for a small
period of time and what you take away
two to three life-changing things so
with whole 30 which is really hard I
lasted 20 days on it it's really tough
it's like a very like iffy extreme Paleo
with some weird stuff thrown in but I'm
a big fan of it and you do whole 30 and
you'll learn one to cook more than you
ever have before you'll learn that
there's added sugar and just about
everything and that sriracha is
delicious because it's full of sugar and
Cholula is less sugar so you're allowed
to eat that some deserve reason and and
you'll learn about sort of the way your
body feels when you're just eating kind
of good food and so these are like
things that you can take away and stick
to and the whole thirty folks actually
talked a lot about how almost a hard wig
the co-founder talks a lot about how
it's not supposed to be for 365 days so
the diet tells you you're going to do
this for the rest of your life and
you're never going to have walk and
chips and you're never going to have ice
cream again like that's not for me and I
imagine it's not for most people in this
audience though if it is like props to
you and I'd love to eat your guac and
chips but I think that that's a major
shift that's happening so anyway I think
the idea is not to actually like try to
change behavior necessarily but to lean
into trying to improve like the effect
of when that you know kind of rise in
motivation exists and totally how are
you um
where this has a really huge audience
can you elaborate more on the marketing
and what you've found to be successful
to grow and also attract your unique
visitors yeah so we do things really
differently I actually spoke at con-con
which is the event that the hustle put
on before this I remember I left
memory and and what we talked about was
I have this like extremely strong belief
that what you need to be doing is
producing a lot less content that's a
lot more awesome and that in a world
where the distribution networks have
changed dramatically but are now not
going anywhere you only stick out by
being really really relevant to a small
niche group and by super serving them
and so that's what we do in health and
wellness which is a space that sort of
typifies by people not doing that you
know people make money and help them all
this the easy way because it's easy for
like most of time and so what we do is
we produce signs back to expert approved
content that's terrifically legitimate
we produced a very small amount of it
compared to anybody that we ever we get
compared to and we tend to perform
really well on places that you might
think are less sexy places like Google
search places like Pinterest people come
back and when they come they spend over
seven minutes on every article page on
average which is like that really read
the content which is like a crazy thing
in media apparently so you know my
opinion is that it's it's not what you
think it's not about sort of
spray-and-pray
it's actually about finding your niche
audience engaging them terrifically and
you know in growing that audience over
time it doesn't happen overnight
so we're that there's no mic over there
right hope none of you have questions go
ahead bit of a similar question I was
wondering what was the number one
strategy used to first build your
audience and how did that change when
you got to the stage of scaling that
audience yeah number one like what's the
thing that worked or number one is in
what's the first thing I tried that flop
disastrously
I would say what's the one you would
prioritize now that you know looking
back
so look greatest started six years ago
and the world was very different the way
that we drew like first dick thing
that we did was we reached out to 100
top influencers in the space I was like
oh you know I read voraciously
so voraciously that I used to work very
slowly just now out it's embarrassing
so I read like crazy and I knew all the
people that I admired in the space and
so I reached out to them was like hey
I'm launching this site I want your help
how do way we reach normal people just
trying to get better and a voice
election empower them to improve and
those a hundred people when I actually
later was like okay we launched the site
ended up sharing it today that's an
influencer strategy and if that's your
strategy like you better have a billion
dollars because it's it's shifted in
such a different way so that was a
strategy that sort of worked then the
next thing that sort of changed the game
for us was we hitched a ride on
Pinterest
what bandwagon it was an early we were
all using it in the office it was just
starting to grow in like late 2011 we
decided to double down on this platform
that has become one of the largest
platforms on the internet and we just
honestly got it right we committed to
improving all of our content in a way
that was more visual and more driven we
sort of looked at that and we're like
we're going to own this for health and
wellness and food and drink which at the
time were the third and fourth most
popular categories or something like
that and so we just keep like really
hitched a ride to this and and the
challenge now is like what is that
platform and so you know it would still
give the same advice which is how do you
find a platform that's growing that you
believe in that is really really truly
like some of your audiences on and start
like growing from there it's harder to
do than ever before because the
gatekeepers are there are less of them
now and it's and it takes more resources
to get ahead so it's like you're
thinking oh well the answer is video
like video is more expensive doing video
right is really and uniquely is really
tough and so I'd encourage everyone who
wants to build a media brain with to
build an audience to focus on a very
very specific demographic and then try
to make it like 10 times more specific
than that and super like super super
serve them in a way that actually they
basically like you become there must
read or there must follow or there must
share otherwise you're screwed
there's a you know
like general content for people it just
doesn't work anymore and I don't know
why it would and I'm upset that it ever
did good either
could you talk a little bit about any
sort of frameworks heuristics or giving
your editorial strategy of content
strategy the things that you guys use as
your North Star to make decisions
whether it's what you're going to
publish or not publish or what you're
investing in or where you're spending
your time um talk talk as much as you're
able to about how you make decisions
within the company yeah choosing what to
cover is really hard actually especially
if you have limited resources it's a
great question and it's not easy we've
gone we've we've changed a lot over time
in terms of how we approach it I would
say roughly the way it breaks down is
about 30% like a third of the dirty 3.3
33 a third of the decisions that we make
come from numbers right it's like what's
working for us what's working for other
people about a third comes from our
internal editors and like their judgment
and this is really kind of crucial
because it's it's like you have to trust
the people that know what they're doing
and then about a third comes from like
the outside world which is you know like
what's trending in Google for example so
it's sort of this mixture of the three
and it's absolutely an art more than a
science because we write two or three
articles a day which again might seem
like a lot to you guys that you know the
people were sort of competing with so
the people who usually people compare
and are like oh you're just like that
other media company they're writing 50
to 500 articles a day so you know we
think of it as like we have very few
shots on goal we got to make take a hell
a good shot I obviously I'm not a sports
guy or else maybe that would make that
metaphor better so I don't know if that
answers your question but that's how we
think about it and it changes over time
and it's and it's it's like you know
you're constantly trying to provide
something that's different and providing
something that's different can just be
your voice just your tone and it can
just be sort of that how comprehensively
how you frame and package it you know
how you're speaking online how you're
bringing content we probably produce
meaningfully more content everyday
that's built for each of the social
channels that we're trying to build an
audience on that we do for our site
proper which is crazy so you know this
it all continues to evolve and shift
go ahead every time I have them like
bunch of questions as you keep talking
but I'll stick with my initial which was
how did you know when to quit your day
job and go to this full force and how
did you know who to hire when to hire
you know how did you realize we have the
funds to do it you know just as a
surprise yeah how did I figure out
everything and yeah well what I'll start
with is that I think like I'm broken
I've been building stuff my whole very
short life I don't think that's the only
way to build businesses I think people
build businesses for lots of different
reasons and lots of different stages in
their lives but I from like an in middle
school and high school and college I
served organizations that are all still
around are all still growing honestly
they're all bigger and better than when
I was there which is kind of cool and
actually flattering but also like what
does that say about me
that's like I've always started new
stuff and I'm surprised time and time
again by people who are drawn to sort of
entrepreneurship for reasons that I
think are wrong like I don't know how
else I don't know what else to do and
I'm a shitty employee I always have been
and like I have always believed that I
can do better something in this world
like truly that I can do it better than
anybody else that's totally not normal
and I hope very few people think that
because it's kind of messed up but it's
I think the only feeling you need to
have when you're trying to start a
business it's like this bubble this I
think of it as like you've got a lot of
like idea bubbles and one like bubbles
to the top and you're like I need to do
that and nobody can do this better than
me and it's a crazy thought to say that
when you have no remote experience
and so my opinion on this is if you're
considering quitting your day job to do
something entrepreneurial it does
research a no-brainer to you you have to
be sitting there saying you know I think
if you're truly asking yourself that
question it's probably not right for you
would be my strong opinion and that you
should have it should be such a feeling
like
of course I have to do this and so
that's my very strong opinion on that I
don't know if that's helpful I feel like
I just scared everyone I have two
questions and I'll ask both of them
first should be straightforward I think
what's the most popular piece of content
you've ever published oh man that's a
great question
it is 17 or 24 portable high protein
snacks it's true right now the number
one thing that's trending actually is 24
tricks at 24 24 tricks to stay cool
during the summer when you don't have an
AC and everything is science fact and
expert approved what but yeah those have
been it's mostly food food it does
terrifically well for us and the second
question is as you grow to compete with
these traditional media companies how do
you think about a comScore number which
is going to be used by the pngs and huge
companies that might be coming to you
with ad dollars
yeah we think about it too much probably
you know there's a like funny constant
struggle between like hey we're
different we're not doing things like
the other people we're the upstart as
someone said and we're going to
transform and disrupt and be different
but also we want your money and how do
you decide to give us your money
oh it's with all the metrics that
everyone else is using and so it's a
constant battle actually and there's no
really simple solution you'd like to
think that you can actually push the
market forward and actually define the
market in a different way which is what
we do you know things like experiences
branded content you know it those are
hard to quantify and so that's what
people want from you that's what you
could sell in a very different way but
yes of course we have a comScore number
every month we're like wish it was
larger and it's a you kind of have to
play the game a little bit and as much
as I always want to be like you don't
understand like we do think so
differently you can't even put us on a
chart but people need charts to decide
how to spend money especially if they're
at P&G and are worried about getting
fired by their boss if they make a silly
decision so it's a balance
just like everything in health
everything is a talents good thanks
Derek um so say you wanted to start a
media company you think you've
identified a good niche made it specific
have an idea on how to super serve them
what's a quick way to validate like if
those people are going to care by your
content without like slaving at it for
five months and spending money getting
your content out there I think you
should slave at it for five months I
mean you could write a blog post on your
own you know in the early days of
greatest I say a lots of people that if
you can't start the business on your own
you shouldn't start it or you should
find a co-founder who can help you build
it every now and then someone's like I'm
going to build an app and you're like oh
cool I love apps so I get apps um and
they're like but you know all I know how
to do is strategy consulting and you're
like all right well that strategy
consulting is cool but do you know how
to build an app and if they don't I
worry about how they're going to put the
resources together make the right
decisions you can find the right people
to work with and so I always encourage
people if you're going to build a media
company like write and edit like you
should be or find someone who's like
going to start with you who can do it
too
so first I would say like create some
stuff put it out there it's definitely
never been easier to test people's
reactions because of Facebook because of
you know social media you can both put
stuff out there you can pay to get it
promoted and see what the reactions are
but yeah I actually believe a lot of
times that people over eight sort of the
I'm going to just put a sealer out there
and see how people respond to react I
think a lot of times the things that are
truly again most of people that are
speaking on the stage built something
that didn't exist before and that no one
was like man what I really need is a
protein bar that has slightly less
calories and less sugar but high protein
and is made of good ingredients like
nobody was sitting there actively maybe
thinking that and so I think you know
like that's the way to be is like the
world needs this I keep always thinking
about the Henry Ford quote which is like
if your desk - what they wanted they
would have wanted a faster horse a
realtor's really sure that's a myth and
not a real quote but it's a good one
yeah go ahead a large publisher what do
you think of programmatic guides and you
know assuming that you think it's broken
how would you fix it and programmatic if
you're producing really high quality
content as shooting programmatic is like
a great way to move upstream and make
more money
programmatic for those of you that don't
know is basically like if you display
advertising that you're monetizing
through a waterfall and the waterfall is
like you get to choose which vendors are
bidding on your on your inventory and so
it's a big thing a lot of people are
moving to their in particular a lot of
big brands are moving a lot of their
spending there which is very frustrating
if you're trying to convince them and
money on branded content they're like
nah I'm good I just want to spend money
using robots to decide what to buy I
think it's really smart for the industry
honestly I think for a publisher you
can't possibly get by on just
programmatic I think it's really hard
unless you've got like I don't know 300
million unique visitors something and I
welcome anybody who's innovating to try
and improve the quality of the ads and
the relevance of the ads because our
content and our audience is real and so
that helps us but doesn't help everyone
it's a mess of the thing though
programmatic yeah so I know there's a
lot of controversy and diets especially
things like fat intake and I'm curious
when your experts disagree with each
other out and resolve that and you know
prevent being safe news all right this
is unfortunately the last question and
so sorry
but it says times up in very scary red
letters so I have to trust that I will
answer this question though
because I think it's really crucial some
of you might have heard recently the
coconut oil is the devil for you and it
has saturated fat it always did and
saturated fat is not bad for you and the
American Heart Association which makes
recommendations like when you read that
site I guarantee you any of the
recommendations will be like oh this is
a hard thing to trust that is not bad
for you so long story but but you'd be
surprised at how much we don't
agree with the science health and
wellness is sounds controversial a lot
of the time a lot of things in health
sound like everyone disagrees but
honestly it's mostly traditional media
just trying to confuse the out of
you and there's a general scientific
consensus about almost about many many
things if not almost all major things in
health and wellness today now that
doesn't mean it's not going to evolve
and change but there's a general
scientific consensus and so you'd be
surprised how rarely people actually
disagree internally remember we have
every article that needs it approve by
least two experts sometimes we'll bring
in five because there are so many
different varying takes I'm waiting for
Sam to like run out and drag me off
I really appreciated being your lunch
entertainment and I think nicki minaj is
next thanks
[Applause]